democrats roll out their newest
orwellian woke term
president biden decides to destroy the
companies that just saved america from
the pandemic
and the biden administration has no idea
the taxpayers actually paid the bills
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
today's show is sponsored by express vpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
slash ben will get all the news in just
one moment first your cell phone bill
does not have to be as expensive as it
is it is just that simple
there's no reason for you to overpay for
your cell phone coverage from a place
like verizon or it and trt mobile switch
over to peer talk it's going to save you
money in fact pure talk saves the
average family of for over 800
a year here's the best part you don't
have to sacrifice coverage because it's
on the exact same network as one of
those providers
switching is super easy you can keep
your phone keep your number or get huge
discounts on the latest iphones and
androids right now
you can get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and
if you go over on data they're not going
to charge you for it just one of the
many reasons they've been named the top
wireless provider by consumer affairs
from your cell phone so i'll pound 250
say
ben shapiro you'll save 50 off your very
first month
that is pound 250 say my name ben
shapiro to get started
right now you're probably talking with
your cell phone provider and they're
telling you well you know you really
need unlimited text and you need
unlimited talk and you need unlimited
data
you don't need a limited data what you
need is unlimited talk text six gigs of
data for 30 bucks a month and again
if you go over with pure tuck they're
not going to charge you for it so you've
got nothing to lose now pound 250
say ben shapiro get started with my
friends at puretalk usa
today okay so democrats have decided to
basically rewrite all of human language
in real time and it is a bizarre
spectacle
and if you notice this then they get
very angry at you right this is the the
full extent of gaslighting
over and over in the past few years
we've seen democrats take terms
that we all understand and all know and
then just switch the meaning of the
terms and then if you notice they get
super pissed at you so for example if
the democrats say let's add seats to the
supreme court
and republicans say okay that's court
packing they say no no no court packing
is when you fill open seats but you're a
republican
and conservatives are like wait hold up
a second that's not what court packing
means
and the entire media suddenly starts
repeating just
like that incredibly quickly the
democrats redefinition of the term court
packing or
for example you have somebody like
maisie hirono the idiot senator from
hawaii
democrat who says to amy coney barrett
the term sexual preference
is now a discriminatory term used
against gay people
as opposed to sexual orientation then
the dictionary dictionary.com will
switch its definition
overnight so suddenly the the term
sexual preference
will be offensive to some people right
they'll actually say it's offensive
just because democrats said so and
they've been doing this over and over
and and to the point where words have no
definitions anymore i mean we have seen
over and over for example
that democrats have no definition of the
word female the word female has no
definition to them
right they refuse to acknowledge that
female refers to a biological female in
fact
female is a category that you can join
simply by saying that you are one
which is an amazing way to define a
category you can't define a word
typically
with reference to the word if i say you
know what the definition of pen is a pen
is a pen i've added no new information
you have no idea what the hell i'm
talking about if you didn't know what a
pen was
in the first place well democrats do
this with language all the time and we
are being forced
into ever more bizarre
redefinitions of of normal human
language all of this does have an impact
by the way it means we can't speak to
each other
because if i use the word woman and
you're a democrat and you buy into the
redefinition of the word woman
you literally have no idea what i'm
talking about and if you use the word
woman i have no idea what you're talking
about because you could mean a dude
right which which is the opposite okay
so
this reared its weird head yesterday
in a congressional hearing about health
disparities
particularly with regard to maternal
mortality for example
and democrats have started to use the
term just in time for mother's day
they've started to use the term birthing
persons
you understand not every birthing person
according to democrats is a woman now
according to all human biology in fact
all mammalian biology
birthing things are female right if you
birth a thing
definitionally you are a female
according to all mammalian biology of
which we know
okay because mammals are sexually
dimorphic to pretend otherwise is to
ignore
basic human biology so to say
birthing person instead of woman is
meant to say there are some men who give
birth
this of course is incredibly silly
because men do not give birth
it is very difficult as it turns out to
grow a baby without a uterus or
to force a baby through your urinal
canal
as a dude anything in kidney stone is
bad try pushing a 10-pound child out of
there
okay so all of this is incredibly silly
but democrats have decided to adopt this
language because of course
they have this perverse view of science
that science
is basically whatever they say it is
without regard to data and without
regard to biology
and if you point out that you need some
sort of objective metric to determine
whether a male is a male or a female is
a female they get very angry at you
male and female are just subjective
categories in your head but they are
also deeply ingrained biologically
understand the contradiction here
according to members of the left
you are a female if you think you are a
female because that is ingrained in your
brain
but also your brain biology has nothing
to do with with whether you are a male
or female and your bodily biology has
nothing to do
with whether you are a male or a female
it's
ghost in the machine cartesian duality
nonsense okay so
all of this came to fruition yesterday
just in time for mother's day now i've
been
for years joking and drives people on
the left on the internet crazy because
ah how why are you even joking about
this
every mother's day and every father's
day instead of tweeting happy father's
day or happy mother's day
i tweet out for mother's day happy
primary guardian of unspecified gender
because according to the left mothers
don't really exist there are just people
who can play the role of mothers and
that could theoretically be a dude
or it could be a lady who identifies as
a dude or it could be a dude who
identifies as a lady it could literally
be anything
and there's nothing special about
mothers there's nothing special about
fathers according to members of the left
this isn't this is not
a fringe idea this is a mainstream idea
a child does not need a mother and a
child does not need a father
a child doesn't need no either one right
a child can have just a father and be
fine he can have just a mother and can
be fine can have two mommies can have
two daddies they're all the same
human beings are interchangeable widgets
and children are completely malleable
and are fine under any circumstances
this has been a long held democratic
philosophy
and now they've gone even further which
is that a mother could be a father or a
father could be a mother and a man could
be a woman and a woman could be a man
so they finally came out with this
yesterday just in time for mother's day
so mom's everywhere you should feel
really flattered you may not be a woman
you're just a birthing person and the
same people who wear handmaids tales
outfits to to protest republican
abortion policy because they say
republicans keep reducing us to our
reproductive organs they keep reducing
us down to our reproductive
abilities call women birthing persons
now
that's what they call them and it wasn't
just one congress person this is going
to be the term
within within the next several months
you are going to see democrats adopting
this term in widespread fashion so
corey bush the adjunct member of the
squad she just joined from missouri
she's a former black lives matter
activist i mean she's actually still a
black lives matter activist she's just
in congress
now she's talking about how birthing
persons are dying
now to you the normal human being who
like
all humans like like all homo sapiens
for the last 300 000 years or so
i've understood that birthing persons
are female you may say to yourself why
are we
now conveying less information why why
are we trying to obscure information
that is clearly obvious
that why don't you say moms instead
you a mother are now a birthing person
according to corey bush
every day black women are subjected to
harshness harsh and racist treatment
during pregnancy and child birth
every day black women die because the
system denies our humanity
it denies us patient care i sit before
you today
as a single mom as a nurse as an
activist and as a congresswoman and i am
committed
to doing the absolute most to protect
black mothers to protect black babies
to protect black birthing people
and to save lives okay black birthing
people okay then she tweeted
out every day black birthing people and
our babies die so she used mothers there
like 10 times and women
so she fully understands that birthing
people are mothers and are women
right she totally gets it but instead
what she tweets is every day black
birthing people
and our babies die and this is the new
term right the new term is
birthing people now again i can't think
of much more degrading to a woman
than to suggest number one that the
process of pregnancy and childbearing
has nothing to do with being a woman
and simultaneously to suggest that you
can be boiled down to just bearing
babies like it is the exact opposite of
what feminism suggested feminism
suggested
that women are different than men and
women ought to be respected
for that and treated equally despite
that difference and in fact because of
that difference
right feminism suggested there's
something special about being a woman
the new feminism is there's nothing
special about being a woman and in fact
men can give birth
all of which is just ridiculous now i've
watched my wife give birth three times
it turns out it's a very female thing
it's a pretty amazing thing it's a
superpower that women hold and she's a
great
womanhood down to nothing is really
incredible
we've been told by the feminist left of
today and the highest achievement that a
woman can have
is to never have kids apparently and to
just spend your time working 2 200
hours at a law firm so you can have a
partner title the same as a man
and delay child bear delay child bearing
delay child rearing delay marriage
this is the best move that you can make
if you finally do have a baby you should
you should you know probably freeze your
eggs and then do it much later so you
can have your career development
you don't need a man to do any of this
sort of stuff now the the amazing thing
about this
is that the people who then end up
getting married and having kids are the
people who promote the same ideology
and the members of the new ruling class
is the point that charles murray makes
and coming apart the people
who are higher on the economic totem
pole
those folks tend to get married and have
kids
it's just all the stuff they preach
filters into the culture and it
undermines marriage
and it undermines child bearing under
healthy circumstances and it's really
stupid
okay but this is something that the left
has been pushing for a long time and now
it's come to its culmination in
desexing having children right now it is
it is a sexless thing
to have children which is an amazing
amazing thing and again it was not just
corey bush representative carolyn
maloney from new york
she says the same thing america's health
system is failing
black birthing people how does one of
the most
medically advanced nations in the world
continue to fail black birthing people
at such high rates to understand we have
to take the blinders
off our history and acknowledge that our
health care system
including reproductive health care was
built on a legacy
of systemic racism okay in a second i'm
going to talk about the systemic racism
point but the fact that you just keep
saying black birthing you mean black
women
why are you being so disrespectful to
women i honest to god don't understand
how women could look at this stuff and
not feel insulted
it's ridiculous it's just it
it's it's beyond crazy but we're all
supposed to believe it
right and if you if you notice this they
get mad if you notice it's like why are
you even noticing this i'm noticing it
because you guys are radically
redefining biology you're radically
redefining reality in front of me and
i'm supposed to just be there like
who cares representative ron
robin kelly from illinois she says the
exact same thing during the same hearing
so obviously the memo went around it's
no longer black women it is black
birthing people
the federal government should support
access to
and the provision of patient-centered
data-driven quality maternal care
enhanced coverage and support for
birthing people during the postpartum
period
and address social determinants of
health including stroke they're looking
at their notes by the way you can stop
it there the the fact that they keep
using the term birthing people the memo
went around
don't don't defend people of the left
who have to virtue signal about the idea
that men could be women
so just to get this straight according
to the left here's how human biology
works you ready for this according to
the left
birthing people gestate meaningless
clusters of cells
and then those clusters of cells exit
the birthing people
and they are assigned sex at birth they
don't have a sex they're assigned it
by a doctor the doctor just looks at
them and randomly and then just assigns
sex at birth and then later
they decide their own sex if this makes
any sense to you it's because you're a
honest to god if this makes any sense to
you it's because you have been
so well educated in the new woke
vocabulary at major american
universities that you've lost your mind
it is denial of fundamental human
reality it is denial of biology
and it does have consequences the
consequences
some of them are smaller and some of
them are larger okay so according to the
left
mothers are just birthing people they
are not special it has nothing to do
with being a woman
which is again deeply insulting to women
so there are three separate
problems with this for american society
problem number one
is sort of the small scale stuff that
tends to make it into the media a lot
because it is the most obviously
ridiculous element of american society
that has bought into this
okay and these small scale cases are
things like transgender people using the
opposite sex bathroom
right it's it's people like yeah a big
hulking man walks into a ladies room at
target
and then says i'm a woman and a woman
feels uncomfortable and then the left
says how dare you
feel uncomfortable how dare you believe
that this is an invasion of your private
space
right or it or it materializes in boys
biological boys wanting to play in
women's sport
and then defeat the girls right as we
saw at these connecticut track meets
where suddenly boys
biological teenage boys were blowing
away the girls of the track meets but
they identified as girls so we had to
pretend that they were girls right we
see these sort of cases
they are statistically rare they are not
indeed happening
everywhere that's not the chief threat
here and to pretend that that is the
chief problem
with this entire idiotic gender ideology
is to mistake a symptom for the actual
problem the symptom is not the actual
problem the symptom's
not great and symptom is stupid and the
symptom is demonstrative of the
underlying problem but it is not
the actual problem so for example a lot
of attention being paid to the fact
that there is uh the summer olympics in
tokyo is coming
and there will be a transgender
weightlifter named laurel hubbard whose
favor to win
the women's medal for new zealand
according to the uk guardian while
hubbard's presence on the new zealand
team has not been made official
an international weightlifting
federation insider confirmed to the
guardian
that she and this is the guardian
reporting because i use biological
pronouns so the zahee
would automatically qualify because of
amended rules approved by the
international
olympic committee current ioc guidelines
dictate that transgender athletes can
participate
in the female categories without
undergoing surgery so long as their
total testosterone level in serum is
kept below 10
nanomoles per liter for at least 12
months a rule followed by the iwf
hubbard lived as a man for 35 years
before identifying as a transgender
woman
and did not win any international
weightlifting titles until transitioning
until 2012.
well there's a shock because it turns
out that being a 35 year old dude who's
like a mediocre weightlifter means that
you're a world-class female weightlifter
because men ain't built the same as
women
okay that's just the reality of the
situation in the same way
the average man will throw a baseball
maybe 45 50 miles an hour 55 miles an
hour
that's not super fast that is faster
than 99 of women throw a baseball
okay so pretending that the man is a
woman doesn't make the man a woman
and a lower testosterone level for 12
months obviously doesn't change the math
all that much
okay so that is the symptomatic stuff
but is that the really serious threat to
society no
there are two really serious threats to
society one is part and parcel of a
greater threat
that has arrived with regard to the
family that when you
redefine family entirely when you
suggest that the nuclear family is the
problem
which has been a hallmark of leftist
thought since karl marx
and before the idea that the nuclear
family is an
obstacle to self-fulfillment that your
parents your father
and your mother having different gender
roles that this
is a barrier to your self-development
this has been a long time part of
thought i mean it's a reason why the
communist manifesto says the destruction
of the nuclear family is necessary
in order so they can we can remold all
of society it turns out that human
beings
have a natural attachment to the nuclear
family unit human beings have a natural
attachment to their wives or to their
husbands they have a natural attachment
that is greater than their other
attachments to their children
i don't care about other people's kids
as much as i care about my kids and if
you say that you do
you're a liar okay the reality is that
you are most attached to the people with
whom you share a family unit you're most
attached to your wife you're most
attached to your husband
and your wife and husband pairs
typically produce
natural born children to whom they are
greatly attached this is just the
reality of human biology
this is what members of the religious
community would call natural law it
doesn't mean it's actually in law
natural law just means that there is a
reality to the world around you and
you can discover the best way to live by
looking at the reality around you okay
so nuclear family
matters an awful lot and people who want
to redesign society in tremendous ways
believe the nuclear family is an
obstacle it's why black lives matter
says
destruction of the nuclear family is
something that they are into that's why
democrats have tried to substitute
government for the father is what they
did in the 1960s
and they're doing so still today they
say they want to help families but then
they want to completely redefine the
family unit by pretending you don't need
a mom or you don't need a dad or the
government can step in for a mom or a
dad or family units can be randomly
redefined and then they look around they
go
wait no kids are being born yeah that's
true you know i know kids are being born
because in order for kids to be born you
have to have a commitment to the idea
of a family in the first place this
doesn't mean that there can't be other
forms of family that have kids
there are right gay couples adopt for
example or have surrogate
kids or kids through surrogates you have
you have single people who are adopting
or people who are having birth out of
wedlock
but the main way that you are going to
increase birth rates in a society
is to have a stable family unit capable
of raising many children at once okay it
turns out
raising kids is super hard work and it
turns out you need a mom and a dad
to really do that with a lot of children
you can have exceptions to that rule but
that is in fact the rule
and when you undermine the family unit
when you pretend that men are women and
women are men and women and men don't
need each other and that you can
generate all this stuff in a lab or the
government can fill in what you end up
with is declining birth rates
and then the solution to declining birth
rates according to these folks
is not to go back to a more traditional
view of what men and women do and none
of that is to say that women have to
stay in the home
and that women can't go to work my wife
and i have three kids
we make provision for my three kids so
my wife can work when she wants to work
which is the way that you know we have
chosen to live our lives when i was
growing up my mom went to work and my
dad stayed home
you make these sorts of bargains in
everyday life but that does not change
the fundamental basis of a nuclear
family
and there's a reason why religious
families who are very committed
to basic fundamental family structure
have many many more children than people
who are committed to the idea that
families can randomly be assembled from
any sort of randomly generated
assemblage of ours
okay there's a reason why we have a
father's day and a mother's day is
because typically speaking a child needs
a mother and a father
and a mother and a father are well
equipped to have many natural children
who they them raise together
that is the goal right that has always
been the goal of not only western
societies but most societies over the
course of time
okay but the solution now is because the
left has gone too far here
because the left has has helped destroy
family structure
their solution is not let's go back to a
more traditional notion of how we
support families
now their idea is what if government
helped right what if government came in
and helped right so instead of going
back to men
women they need each other they produce
natural children instead of that they're
like well what if the government just
did it
they have a piece by katherine rample
over at the washington post noting the
us economy needs more kids yeah no
no bleep that's true the us economy does
need more kids you know what used to
provide lots of kids
the nuclear family in a traditional
religious community that used to provide
lots of kids you know it still provides
a lot of kids
the nuclear family in a traditionally
religious community the average number
of kids
in my community in the orthodox jewish
community is minimum four
okay that is that like my wife and i
have three
with the help of god we'll have more if
we have fewer than five or six
we are on the low end of the orthodox
jewish community if you go into the
mormon community right a very religious
community
the number of kids and families over
there it ain't two okay they're
reproducing it well above replacement
rates if you go into traditional
catholic families the same thing is true
you'll see six seven eight kids that is
not
merely because of ideological objections
to contraception in some cases
that's really because of an ideological
commitment to the basic idea which is
that men and women are meant to be
together and then have children together
right religious people take seriously
both the biblical injunction to be
fruitful and multiply but also the
natural law injunction that this is sort
of what you're here to do is to produce
the future generation
and raise that future generation and
it's amazing to me that we have created
a society
where the most important thing that you
do as a human being which is to have
children and pass on
good values to those children to build
for the future has become something that
we discard as you know it's just
something birthing people do
oh it's just something birthing people
do it's not an important part of life
it's just something you could do or you
could not do
your choice now it's a free country it
is your choice
but we should be encouraging that choice
instead we have an entire society that
has decided
that that choice is stupid and then
there are consequences to that right so
when
i mention the consequences that are kind
of fringy then you have the consequences
that are real like declining birth rate
okay that is a result of the sexual
revolution that is a result of the
rethinking of male and female roles
that is a result of the rethinking of
the nuclear family and the nuclear
structure nuclear family structure
and how many kids people think people
ought to have we'll get some more of
this in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that if you
are a dude
one thing that is very painful as you
hit your 30s is you realize that you're
starting to lose your hair
that is no fun well if you'd like to
keep your hair i have a solution for you
for hims.com it's your one stop shop for
hair loss and wellness
for men thanks to science baldness can
now be optional hymns is helping dudes
be the best version of themselves with
licensed medical providers and fda
approved products to help treat hair
loss
no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements prescription
solutions backed by science
hymns was created by a guy who knows
some men's health conversations are
easier online than in person
no more awkward in-person doctors visits
or long pharmacy lines
four hymns connects you to licensed
medical professionals online that could
save you hours completely confidential
completely discreet
answer a few quick questions a medical
professional will review if they
determine it's right for you you can
prescribe your medication
to treat hair loss that is shipped
directly to your door today
hymns is giving you the best offer yet
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days hymns will give you a full
refund right now
my listeners can get their first visit
absolutely free go to for hims.com
that is for hims.com prescription
products require an online consultation
with a healthcare provider who'll
determine if a prescription's
appropriate restriction supplies you
website for full details and important
safety information remember that is for
hims.com ben go check them out
right now okay so problem number one as
i mentioned
is these sort of fringy problems of
transgender athletes who want to
out-compete girls because they are in
fact biological male
and problem number two is the complete
rethinking
of family structure the nail of maleness
and femininity and the consequences that
has for things like the formation of
nuclear family
and yes things like having children and
living
a a lifestyle that produces children and
rears children in a safe and healthy
context
those things are kind of important for
any growing society
and i i'm amused to see how many people
on the left are suddenly realizing hey
we need more kids
yeah got it say according to catherine
ramble the u.s economy needs more kids
parents say they want more kids
yet the baby bust has gotten worse the
general fertility rate that is the
number of births per thousand women aged
15 to 44 how dare she the number of
births per
thousand birthing people aged 15 to 44
declines
55.8 in 2020 that's a record low for the
united states
birth rates decline for every racial and
ethnic group and nearly every age group
covid 19 the associated economic stress
were partly to blame lockdowns in social
distancing disrupted new courtships and
already partnered americans put off
pregnancies as well
but they'd been declining earlier in
2020 and during each of the five
proceeding years now a lot of people say
that one of the things that happens is
that as countries get richer
they have fewer children this is
generally true okay one of the reasons
for that is that the economic bargain of
having children goes away
in poorer countries one of the reasons
that a lot of people have kids is
because those kids are seen as labor
resources right in super poor countries
the idea is
you have a lot of kids and those kids
help take care of you those kids are out
there working the fields those kids are
helping you in your business
but there's something else in rich
countries people who are religious and
who still feel
feel a religious and moral obligation to
have children continue to have children
is what you see for example in israel
which which reproduces at well above
replacement rates
right israel is reported they're having
like 2.6 kids per couple a lot of that
is driven by the religious community
secular communities don't have as many
children because they are looking at
children purely as almost an economic
resource that does not mean secular
people see their own kids as an economic
resource it means generally societally
people tend to make economic decisions
about kids when they're a net economic
benefit they have more of them when they
are net economic loss they cost you
hundreds of thousands of dollars
people tend to have fewer of them and in
fact what you see in the united states
is a
very strong correlation in terms of the
data between who wants more kids and who
has
more education in fact people who have
less education in the united states want
to have more kids and people have more
education in the united states want to
have fewer kids
which is again demonstrative of the idea
that gender theories being pushed
by the people who are the post-graduates
and the college graduates
are really bad for the country they're
really bad
okay we should all be aspiring to have a
solid number of children above
replacement rates it is good to have
kids
it is hard work it is difficult it makes
you a responsible person it makes you a
better human being
it means the i really believe this you
can choose to do whatever you want i'm
not imposing on your freedom i'm not
suggesting any legislation to that
effect i'm suggesting that if you want
to better yourself as a human being
and become more responsible getting
married and having kids is an excellent
way to do it
beyond that you're doing something
excellent for the world by having
children and raising them properly
the fact that any of this has become
remotely controversial is a
demonstration of precisely the point i'm
making which is when you undermine
gender roles and when you pretend
that gender can be completely
substituted in favor of biological sex
and that there's no connection between
them
you end up destroying things that are
incredibly valuable in a society
catherine rample's solution by the way
is that the government should get
involved and pay people to have kids
good luck for that it ain't gonna the
the chance that that works
after you have culturally destroyed the
institution of family and marriage
we'll see how that works for you yeah
we'll pay people to have a few more kids
that's that's definitely gonna work out
well
okay so that is problem number two with
this whole thing problem number three
is perhaps the deepest problem of all
which i alluded to at the very top of
the show
okay that problem is that when you
redefine human language
in completely arbitrary ways you destroy
any basis for conversation
and this is a a key element of the
radical subjectivist position that is
taken
by the deconstructionist left
deconstructionism is a philosophy that
suggests that basically semantics are
power
that the way that language is used the
way we think about things all of that is
the product of our civilization and
therefore
if we wish to change our civilization we
have to change the way that words are
used
but that means that we have to recognize
that basically all language is a social
convention without any relation to
objective reality and so it can be
changed at whim
and if you fail to go along with those
changes then you are considered unwoke
you have to be cast out you're
considered a heretic
and there is no rhyme or reason to this
the language can change at any time for
any reason you can find yourself on the
wrong side of the line which means that
language becomes a power
game deconstructionists believe that
there is no such thing as fundamental
principles in politics they don't exist
the only principle
presumably is that everything is power
okay well for the left
everything is power including language
and so when they randomly shift terms
around
and then declare you heretical or
bigoted or racist
or sexist because you refuse to abide by
their idiotic new conventions in which
equity is the same as equality and
sexual preference is an offensive term
for no reason
or male means female if you refuse to
abide by that
then they attempt to cudgel you they
attempt to club you because the idea is
that language
is power and the randomly shifting
attempts to
fluid to take what are terms with real
definitions
and then fluidify them liquidate them
and and shift them around
that is just an exercise of power
recognize that that's what that is
and that exercise of power is designed
to confuse
the it's no different than god's attempt
to confuse the people who are building
the tower of babel
once everybody is speaking a different
language you can't build anything
together
right in the bible god does that because
these people are building a societal
construction designed to challenge godly
values
but now the left is trying to do this
because they're trying to prevent
you from building any sort of societal
structure that challenges their values
so they have to confuse the language
they have to completely change the
language and if you refuse to go along
with the changes
then this means that you shall be cast
out like a leper
hey that's a dangerous thing in order
for us for in order for us to have a
polity
in order for us to have any sort of of
policy and
any sort of democratic republic together
we have to understand what the hell
we're talking about
the left throws up barriers to
understanding on a routine basis
and then they suggest that you are just
a buffoon or a fool if you don't
understand what they're saying i
understand what you're saying i just
think that you're wrong you're lying
i think that corey bush well understands
that women are the only ones giving
birth i think so does carolyn maloney
and robin kelly
and i think they're liars when they
pretend that men give birth i think they
know full well
that that kids have a sex when they are
born
but the goal here is to take the most
fundamental elements
of reality things that small children
can identify
and confuse you about them because it is
an exercise of power
top down and that's truly dangerous
stuff it destroys our ability to have
conversations
it destroys our ability to even convince
one another because we're speaking in
two different languages now
it is it is a way of making people
initiate
into the woke ruling class that is all
this is
and if you refuse to go along then
you're one of these benighted bitter
clingers that barack obama used to talk
about
okay in just a second we're going to get
to joe biden who's declared he just
can't understand republicans anymore
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact that we are
now almost halfway
through the year head into june with one
less thing to worry about see if you're
overpaying for your home and auto
insurance
policy genius makes it easy to compare
home and auto insurance in one place
they can help you find home and auto
coverage similar to what you have now
but
at a lower price they've saved shoppers
up to 1055
per year over what they were paying for
home and auto insurance their team will
handle the paperwork to set up your new
policy or
switch over your current one getting
started is super simple first
head on over to policygenius.com answer
a few quick questions about yourself and
your property
then policy genius takes it from there
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate to
find
your lowest quotes the policy genius
team can look for ways to save you more
including
bundling your home and auto policies if
they find a better rate than what you're
paying now they will switch you over
for free their top-notch service has
earned policy genius a five-star rating
across thousands of reviews
on trustpilot and google policy genius
does an excellent job of getting you the
best of programs available for the best
possible price head on over to
policygenius.com to get started right
now that's policy genius when it comes
to insurance
it's nice and very important to get it
right that's policygenius.com now quick
reminder daily wire we've been growing
like crazy not only did we move our
whole company across the country
we released our first feature film in
january we struck up a movie deal with
gina carano in february we launched a
new talk show hosted by candace owens in
march
we got debunked going that's my new show
we have brand new stuff
that is going to come out for you this
month and in future months we are moving
fast
thank you for your support because
without your subscriptions none of this
would be possible without your
membership and we want to include you in
our future plans so every day on the
show
you know i talk about a bunch of
products and services from sponsors i
love
and use and testify too but we want to
know what kind of sponsors
you want to hear from please go to
dailywire.com shapiro fill out my
audience survey
tell us a little more about yourself to
sweeten the whole experience those of
you who complete the survey will be
entered to win
a 1 000 gift card you can only take the
survey once per daily wire show so if
you want to increase your chance of
winning a thousand bucks go listen to
michael knowles or andrew claven or matt
walsh get access to their surveys as
well again
my survey link is dailywire.com shapiro
would love to hear from you also
starting tomorrow saturday may 8th
at the first episode of my new series
debunked on my podcast feed a new
episode every saturday for the first
season if you're not familiar i address
common leftist talking points dismantle
them in about 15 minutes or less so you
should probably go check it out
dailywire members can get the full
10 episode first season over at
dailywire.com if you're not already a
member
get 20 off today with code debunked
while the discount lasts
first i debunk the fallacy of a living
minimum wage that we need a
minimum wage it's required we debunk
that check it out tomorrow on my podcast
feed over at apple spotify or
whatever your platform of choice maybe
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile joe biden says he
just can't understand republicans
anymore so
the media are committed to the idea that
joe biden's moderate who wants to work
across the aisle he's demonstrated
zero interest in doing this zero and in
fact he's pursuing more and more radical
policy which we'll explain in just a
minute
but because the media are committed to
this narrative where biden is a moderate
and everybody who opposes him is a
radical they will just believe him when
he's like i don't even recognize
this republican party anymore not just
because i'm senile and i can't recognize
my own face in the mirror
but also because shama dabadu does
habitu
here's the president of the united
states
do you have any comments from the
efforts to outline from the house
republicans
i don't understand the republicans i
don't understand republicans anymore
or the abc's okay so here's the thing
the reason that republicans don't get
along with joe biden is because joe
biden
is not a moderate joe biden is a radical
and his policies
are crappy they are bad here's an
indicator that his policies suck
okay so joe biden is out there bragging
that he's created so many jobs
so many jobs now he has created zero
jobs okay the reason
that the economy is rebounding has
nothing to do with joe biden has to do
with the fact that we had 3.5
unemployment before the pandemic then we
had an artificial government shutdown of
the entire economy for a year
and now people are coming back out and
they are starting to work again
and so that has nothing to do with joe
biden and in fact joe biden's policies
are providing a damper on economic
development because
he is paying people to stay home he's
out there bragging about this stuff but
he fails to understand a basic reality
in the united states the government
does not create the jobs the government
unless it's directly hiring you does not
create the jobs
people like me create the jobs people
like corporations like my company
create the jobs corporations out there
and our company is only 130 people 140
people there are corporations that
employ tens of thousands of people
they're small businesses that employ
hundreds of thousands of people across
the united states joe biden has created
this many jobs his entire career okay
because every job he has created
throughout his entire career would have
been created by another senator
or another presidential candidate he has
never worked in the private sector for
any serious period
i mean he created a job for hunter i
guess that's the job he created because
he let hunter go around picking up bags
of cash because his last name is biden
but here's joe biden taking credit for
economic development this is
all by the way i hated when when trump
would say i've created this many jobs no
you didn't create that many jobs
you created conditions under which
businesses could create jobs
maybe but joe biden has not even done
that right joe biden
has basically created the conditions
whereby employees cannot go back to work
or refuse to go back to work because
they're getting paid more to stay home
here is joe biden saying we've created
so many jobs
one of the things that
that i'm proud of is in the first 100
days
that i became president we have
created more jobs in that period of time
than any administration in history but
the way i look at that that's just the
down payment getting us back for the
american recovery act
just getting us back and getting people
a lot of that had to do with getting
people vaccinated
getting 600 million doses of of the
of the vaccine and getting
people in the position where it was
available this batty old coot
doesn't even know what he's talking
about and then he says things like yeah
my infrastructure bill will create 16
million jibabuz
okay it's not going to even by the cbo
estimate
it creates something like three million
jobs over baseline and only costs like
two trillion dollars so that means that
we could spend you know like a hundred
thousand dollars a job
makes perfect sense or several hundred
thousand dollars anyway here's joe biden
being an idiot
all the economists including the liberal
as well as conservative think tanks
point out will create a foot pass this
job final crap create up to
16 million good paying jobs not
eight dollars an hour twelve dollars not
fifteen dollars prevailing wage
jobs wages you can raise the family on
whenever
my dad would say just a little bit of
breathing room i don't know
as engineers like steve carell in
in the gym in in that jim carrey movie
in bruce almighty steve carella
so i'm glad that we have a president who
speaks english as his second language
that's that's exciting stuff
and by the way that wasn't even his
worst stumbling over himself his worth
stumbling over himself yesterday again
it's just some wonder that he didn't
fall backward into the water thank god
what's the first thing
anybody ask you when they want to put a
new facility here in your city
how close is the interstate how you know
what's the access to
the lake what's going i mean what's the
water supply
they want to know you have the best
infrastructure i'm willing to hear ideas
from both sides i'm meeting with my
republican friends up in the
up in the congress to see number one how
much they're willing to go for
what they think of the priorities and
what compromises meet men i'm ready to
compromise
what oh my god okay so here's the thing
the reason that he has no support among
republicans is because what he is doing
is radical and it has consequences first
the consequences and then what he is
doing so
here are the consequences in april the
economy of the united states
in the middle of emerging from pandemic
with people beginning to go outside
beginning to live life again even though
joe biden tells them not to and we have
to wear masks and never dance again
unless you're protesting for george
floyd in which case you're immune but
according to the washington post the
economy picked up 266 000 jobs in april
fewer than expected as economy tries to
rebound hmm
why would this have happened why we had
3.5
unemployment a year ago people have more
money in their pocket now than they did
a year ago because the government has
blown money into their pocket
and yet no one is taking a job hmm i
wonder why
the unemployment rate remained
relatively unchanged at around six
percent
although economists caution the number
is misleadingly low given how many
people have dropped out of the labor
force in the last year
and thus are not counted as unemployed
hiring has accelerated so quickly in
fact some businesses have complained to
the white house and lawmakers
they're having a hard time recruiting
workers particularly for low-wage hourly
jobs
well yes that is correct
you have created rent moratoria you have
suggested that we are to pay
unemployment for like another year
you have given people thousands and
thousands of dollars
who have jobs many of them and people
are like okay or i could sit home the
tension spilled into public on thursday
when senate majority lead minority
leader mitch mcconnell blamed the
stimulus package passed by the white
house in congress
for acting as an incentive for people
not to return to work biden
administration officials countered the
1.9
trillion stimulus package provided vital
assistance to millions of americans and
has only helped the economy grow oh
really
the us economy added almost a million
jobs in march but
um yeah not in april not in april
because it turns out the supply chains
are over strained there are not enough
employees out there
we are leading to an inflationary spiral
because once you have too much money in
the economy
and not enough product to meet that
price you end up with price inflation
and when it turns out that people look
at those prices and think they are too
high they stop buying which is how you
end up with stagflation you end up with
an economy with low demand but high
supply of dollars
that is stagflation that's 1970 style
stagflation and it's coming faster than
anybody thought it was going to come
meanwhile joe biden's big plan is that
he's going to destroy
the companies that helped get us out of
the pandemic so
take for example modern madonna had
developed mrna technology
that allowed for the decoding of this
coveted 19 virus and the production of a
an extraordinarily effective vaccine
within like
nine months of the actual release of the
virus so that the virus
the actual coding of the virus was
released in january 2020. within one
week scientists at places like pfizer
and moderno and bio
and bioentec had actually created mrna
vaccine maps and then it took because of
all the government regulation and red
tape it took months and months and
months for that to hit market which is
just the case that the government sucks
at everything
because they do okay but the government
did one thing basically the government
said
okay well we will give you we will
guarantee you that we will order
your vaccines and will give emergency
authorization if you develop them
and so these companies because they
wanted to develop intellectual property
that was marketable
went ahead and made the greatest
scientific advancement since basically
the moon landing they said we will
develop this vaccine inside of 10 months
and inoculate everyone
now joe biden has decided i'm going to
punish those companies
those companies must be punished now
here's the stupidest thing about all of
this
the supposed justification for punishing
those companies
by stealing their intellectual property
by the way is that
we need to get more doses into more arms
in the third world except that if you
want to get more doses into more arms in
the third world you know what you could
do
you could just buy the doses the same
way that israel or the uk or the united
states did
and then give them to the third world
but we're not doing that instead
joe biden in the bible administration
because they hate big tech because they
hate
big pharma the people who got us out of
this okay big pharma got us out of this
nacho biden not even donald trump big
pharma got us out of this
okay because they hate big pharma this
much they're now trying to steal their
intellectual property
they're trying to say that they should
not have patent on the vaccines they
develop so let's say you're moderna
and let's say that the history of modern
john podhorst did a good job detailing
this on
his commentary magazine podcast the
history of modern is pretty fraud
modernist starts
they have uh early successes and then
they develop a couple of drugs that fail
and their stock starts to go down but
they have all of this leftover mrna
technology they've been working on for
years
then this virus hits and medora ramps up
and suddenly they have this incredibly
successful vaccine
okay so what are you going to do now
you're going to punish them out of
existence by destroying all profit
margin
for the vaccine that they created that
is going to get the united states out of
this pandemic
and indeed get most of the world out of
this pandemic you're going to do so by
removing their intellectual
property understand intellectual
property theft is theft when china does
it we call them
a cheater when joe biden does it we call
that democratic policy
if china were to just create a knockoff
of a pfizer bioentech vaccine
then we would say they're stealing our
intellectual property because they are
but if joe biden does it no problem
whatsoever and again this will not get
more shots into more arms
you know how long it's going to take for
them to ramp up the generic production
of this drug
you know how long it's going to take
them to ramp up the development of a
generic
version of this and get it approved and
do all those things
longer you could just pay the damn
companies you could just pay them
because for god's sake they deserve it
they're the ones who actually created
this miracle thing
but according to the wall street journal
president biden genuflected again to
progressives on wednesday by endorsing
an intellectual property waiver at the
world trade organization for covered
vaccines and therapies
this patent heist won't end well for the
us or the world south
south africa and india have been pushing
a resolution at the wto that would force
pharmaceutical companies to hand over
their covered vaccine and therapy ip to
manufacturers in low-income countries
the waiver is backed by some 100 other
low-income countries progressive groups
and more than 100 democratic congress
members of course they just want to
punish these companies of course they do
waiver proponents say breaking patent
protections is necessary
to expand global access this is false
wto's
rules already allow low-income countries
to force drug makers to license their
patents during emergencies though they
must negotiate some agreement with
developers
liberals say this is slowing vaccine
production yet u.s and european drug
companies have already voluntarily
entered
into dozens of licensing agreements with
other manufacturers many in low-income
countries as they work to scale up
production
merck last week announced licensing
agreements with several indian
manufacturers
to produce its investigational
anti-viral drug
but vaccine and drug makers first need
to ensure their partners can safely
manufacture the complex biologic
products this takes time
so does ramping up production of raw
ingredients even so global vaccine
production is accelerating
european governments oppose the waiver
they realize it sets a terrible
precedent
once stolen ip on breakthrough
innovations like moderna and phaser
bioentech mrna vaccines can't be
returned so why did biden surrender
because
progressives hate big pharma they hate
it they want to pretend that government
did all this stuff
government doesn't do any of this stuff
government is garbage at this stuff
this is why democrats get so mad when
you mention this they get mad when you
mention this right jamie dimon
investor extraordinary he came out he's
like you know if you're going to seize
my money i want to know how you're going
to use that is that too much to ask
i think it should be a bipartisan bill
but i think that each piece and every
piece to say
on highways how many miles you're going
to build
how much does it cost when's it going to
get done who's responsible
so i worry about not just the bill but
we're just throwing money it doesn't
work and you know we already have we
already waste tremendous sums of money
so
and and i think we owe that to the
american public to tell the american
public
if you're going to give me your money
i'm going to be a good steward of it and
here's what i'm going to accomplish i'm
going to report back to you
okay that is a basic request right for
anybody who
operates in this space right like i
wonder how my money's being used
this is so telling robert wright she's
the former secretary of the treasury
under
bill clinton he tweeted this out this is
an amazing tweet because it really does
say everything
did i miss when we elected jamie dimon
to manage our taxpayer dollars
i'm noticing a few problems here jamie
dimon is the head of jpmorgan chase ceo
did i miss when we elected jamie dimon
to manage our taxpayer dollars
who's our gang who's r
and did you miss the the the word
taxpayer in the phrase taxpayer dollars
they are
his dollars they are your dollars they
are my dollars
they're not our dollars the government
doesn't have
its own dollars the government seizes
money from people
and then uses the money on random crap
and if you point this out if you point
out that joe biden doesn't create jobs
and that robert reich doesn't control
taxpayer dollars
and if you point out that the government
did not create these vaccines
the vaccine companies created these
vaccines then they get mad and then they
say well i can't work with you i don't
know what happened to you
is it any wonder why people are starting
to get a little bit trepidatious about
the next few years
in the american government pretty
incredible stuff these are radical
people and they're pushing a radical
agenda
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show first you cannot forget to
end your week by checking out
the andrew clavin show drew's shows
every friday he's got an exciting
evening planned for you so head on over
to dailywire.com this evening at 7 pm
eastern tune in i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowski
editing is by adam scie events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin